bonsoir merci d'être avec nous en direct
la première vague de couronnes un virus
apple a servi de leçon selon ou est-ce
que la france est prête à affronter
deuxième vague
non malheureusement le gouvernement n'a
pas tenu compte de ses erreurs et les
reproduit et à dire que nous
professionnels de santé nous avons dû
lors de la première vague gérer non
seulement l'épidémie mais gérer le
manque parce qu'on manquait de tout or
là bas le gouvernement n'a pas pris les
mesures nécessaires et on se retrouve
toujours avec un problème de manque
alors c'est alors comme ça donc très
précisément pour qu'on comprenne bien
de quoi monter vous à l'hôpital
aujourd'hui nous avons les masques
chirurgicaux
par contre nous n'avons pas encore assez
de masques ffp2 masse que bec de canard
très indispensable professionnels de
santé qui ont à faire à face à une
personne malade il nous manque également
d'aider surblouse des gants tout
simplement parce que ben le monde entier
commente ça en même temps est ce qu'il
aurait fallu faire c'est que le
gouvernement réquisitionne des usines de
textile pour les obliger à fabriquer en
france pour la population française
le matériel dont nous avons besoin et il
ne l'a pas fait il ya aussi un manque de
tests vous l'avez souligné dans le
reportage on est loin des 700 nil promis
pour pour lamy maire on est toujours un
peu plus de 500 milles ce qui est
nettement insuffisant alors que l' oms
depuis février disait il faut tester
tester tester
on n'a pas le nombre de tests suffisant
pour tester comme il faudrait on a aussi
un problème de médicaments d'anesthésié
qui perdure et tout ça alors que on est
depuis deux mois on déconfinement et
donc si on se retrouve confronté à une
seconde vague avec une consommation
bien plus importante d'un seul coup on
va on va pouvoir faire face on va de
nouveau se retrouver avec des sacs
poubelles sur le dos vous représentez
les infirmes et comment réagissent
aujourd'hui vos collègues donc quel état
d'esprit se trouve-t-il après plusieurs
mois éprouvants alors bon il ya une
grande colère une grande colère parce
que si vous vous rappelez au mois de
mars le gouvernement avait dit on va
prendre tous les professionnels de santé
qui sont contaminés par le col vide en
maladie professionnelle
or là on juillet on vient de nous
annoncer que non ce sera réservée aux
cas les plus graves des gens
hospitalisés et caetera et donc du coup
les soignants se sentent trahis
c'est comme si on nous disait les y
rentrer dans une maison en flammes et si
vous avez quelque chose va là tant pis
on s'occupera pas de vos proches quoi
donc là on ya un vrai sentiment de
trahir trahison de perte de confiance
qu'elle regarde ce qu'ils portent aussi
sur ces images qu'on voit beaucoup ces
derniers temps de scènes festives sont
distanciation son masque chez les jeunes
notamment
alors vraiment on demande aux gens de
nous aider à les soigner
c'est à dire mais il faut respecter les
mesures barrières
il faut porter le masque lorsque vous
êtes à proximité d'autres personnes dans
les lieux clos vraiment c'est très
important de respecter les gestes
barrières on peut continuer à vivre
c'est simplement une nouvelle forme à
apprendre mais on peut encore une
histoire être dans la convivialité
profiter de l'été simplement bon on va
avoir le mas que les gestes barrière se
laver souvent les mains
roland tendue en début de ce journal une
centaine de villes françaises rendent le
port du masque obligatoire en extérieur
est ce que c'est une mesure aussi qui
rassure là encore c'est une question de
bon sens c'est-à-dire si vous êtes en
extérieur dans un parc
à 50 mètres d'une personne le masque n'a
pas d'intérêt par contre si vous êtes
dans une rue très passante barre oui
faut porter le masque c'est du simple
bon sens
au delà de ce qui est autorisé ou
interdit par une mairie une préfecture
où le gouvernement
il faut que les gens fassent preuve de
bon sens il ya le j'évolue ski il se
transmet par par l'air comme tous j'ai
vu de maladies respiratoires dont des si
vous êtes un maître faut porter un
masque si les deux personnes ont un
masque rien ne peut se passer
merci d'avoir pris le temps de répondre
à nos questions en tirer amoureux porte
parole du syndicat national des
professionnels infirmiers